deep presence and really like honing
that is never going to get you the most
work done on a particular day ever but
it might over the course of a year or a
decade or a career I'm super clear with
my coaching clients they come to me
talking about efficiency and
productivity and optimization and I'm
like all these things are great I want
all these things too but on what time
scale because if I wanted to optimize
over the next 24 hours or even over the
next week let's say I would slam
espresso and red bulls I'd sleep four
hours a night and I would just bury
myself and that'd be super optimal but
not for a month certainly not for a year
so I think that there's the zooming out
and saying hey like what time scale are
we operating on and there the research
is unequivocal if you're talking about
Excellence or success over the Long Haul
being present for the work that actually
matters is perhaps the most important
variable that you can do to set yourself
up for that success